[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم كل عام وانتم بخير اهلا
بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي
نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
واشنطن تقول بان العمليات في سوريا تهدف
لحمايه قوتها وتحذر ايران من التورط في
الهجمات عليها
مصدر في الخارجيه السعوديه يكشف عن
محادثات مع دمشق لاستئناف الخدمات
القنصليه بين البلدين
الموارد البشريه السعوديه تطلق منصه
الكترونيه لتمكين المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه
للقطاع الخاص
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه ايضا
[تصفيق]
خلال اقل من 24 ساعه اكتتاب جود الخير في
السعوديه يجمع قرابه نصف مليار ريال
عائله سعوديه تتوارث مهنه حياكه ثوب
الكعبه منذ اكثر من سته عقود بمجمع الملك
عبد العزيز بمكه
حياكم الله قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي
قال ان العمليات الامريكيه في سوريا ضد
ميليشيات ايرانيه كانت تهدف الى حمايه
القوات والمعدات الامريكيه وخلال مقابله
مع شبكه سي ان ان اكد كيربي ان الولايات
المتحده لا تسعى لصراع مع ايران مشدد على
ضروره الا تتورط طهران في دعم هجمات على
المنشات الامريكيه واضاف البيت الابيض
واضاف البيت الابيض ان تنظيم داعش وجماعات
مسلحه تدعمها ايران ما زالوا يشكلون
تهديدا في سوريا
هذا وكانت القياده المركزيه للولايات
المتحده قد اصدرت بيانا اكدت فيه ان قاعده
عسكريه امريكيه تقع بالقرب من حقل العمر
النفطي في محافظه دير الزور شمال شرق
سوريا تعرضت لقصف صاروخي اسفر عن مقتل
متعاقد امريكي وجرح سته اخرين ووفق البيان
ردت واشنطن على الاستهداف بتنفيذ ضربات
صاروخيه دقيقه على منشات تستخدمها مجموعات
تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني واكدت
القياده المركزيه على ان قواتها جاهزه
للرد على اي هجمات ايرانيه وهي موجوده في
سوريا لضمان هزيمه داعش الامر الذي يصب في
مصلحه امن المنطقه باكملها وليس سوريا
فحسب
هجوم اول نفذته مسيره تعتقد واشنطن انها
ايرانيه استهدفت منشاه صيانه في قاعده
لقوات التحالف قرب الحسكه شمال شرق سوريا
اسفر الهجوم وفق البنتاجون عن مقتل متعاقد
امريكي واصابه اخرين
لترد واشنطن بضربات جويه دقيقه استهدفت
مستودعا للاسلحه في مدينه دير الزور بيان
البنتاغون الضربات الجويه جاءت ردا على
هجوم اليوم وسلسله من الهجمات الاخيره ضد
قوات التحالف في سوريا من جانب مجموعات
تابعه للحرس الثوري
هجوم يضاف الى سلسله من الهجمات التي شنت
في الاشهر الاخيره وتعرضت لها قواعد
ومواقع تابعه للتحالف الدولي وواشنطن في
شمال وشرق سوريا حيث ينتشر مئات من الجنود
الامريكيين في المنطقه ضمن تحالف يقاتل
عناصر داعش الى جانب تقديم الدعم لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ملوك الشيخ العربي
كشف مصر مسؤول في وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
بان محادثات جاريه مع الجانب السوري
لاستئناف الخدمات القنصليه بين البلدين
المصدر اكد حرص الرياض على تسهيل الخدمات
القنصليه للشعبين وبان البحث جاري مع
المسؤولين في سوريا لاستئناف تقديم
الخدمات القنصليه
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معي هنا في
الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي جاسر جاسر في
جاسر حياك الله في نشاط الرابع كل عام
وانتم بخير رمضان كريم اولا في اي اطار
وسياق يمكن فهم هذه الخطوه السعوديه
باتجاه دمشق ربما هي الخطوه
الرسميه الاولى
في في هذا الملف منذ 2011 كيف يمكن
قراءتها بدايه
على مستويين المستوى الاول اذا تكلمنا
عليه اطار الخدمات القنصليه فهذا مستوى
انساني في المملكه نحو مليون يعني وتعاني
من مشكله اجراءات المعاملات ولا كذا وهذه
القطيع لا تؤدي الى نتيجه عمليه في في
المساله في خدمه هؤلاء الناس وايضا تكشفت
الكارثه اثناء الزلزال بصعوبه الوصول
ودخلنا غياب الاتصالات وبالتالي صعوبه
اغاثه ومساعده الذين ضرروا من الزلزال
وقتها الجانب الاخر انا اعتقد المملكه
العربيه نفسها تعمل على استقرار المنطقه
هذا هدف اساسي هذا احد الاهداف المحوريه
هناك جهود عملت مع العراق وحققت نتائج
ايجابيه وضع قلقتي لحد ما لكن النتائج
تعطي مؤشرات اوليه هناك عمل في مساله
استقرار لبنان هناك ايضا عمل في مساله
استقرار سوريا اذا هذه تحققت الخطوه اذا
تحدثنا عن المفصل هذا جانب انساني خدماتي
اولي يتحقق لكنه ايضا يفتح نافذه حوار
والحوار هذا يتطلب هذا هو السؤال ايضا سيد
جاسر انه هل هي تمهيد لاعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع مع دمشق يعني في قراءه هذه
الخطوه في
يعني شكلها الاولي ام انها بدايه
لحوار اصلا مع دمشق قبل عوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وهو ما كان دائما يتحدث عنها
وزير الخارجيه السعودي بان هناك اجماع في
الجامعه العربيه بضروره الحوار مع دمشق
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اعتقد موقوفه
واضحه لا تقدم هدايا مجانيه
متطلبات واضحه تحريصه على عوده سوريا
حريصا تكون ضمن الحضن العربيه حريصا تخرج
سوريا من هالمازق ومن خلايا حزب الله
والخلايا الايرانيه الايرانيه وما تعانيه
صوره يوميا من الضربات الاسرائيليه بسبب
هذا الانتهاك سوريا يعني دوله فيها جانب
معين يعني تعبث فيها مجموعه دول تركيا
وايران وحزب الله طبعا هو جانب يعتبر من
ايران لكن ايضا وامريكا وروسيا
في منطقه يعني في جوانب منهم السباحه في
الجانب الاخر فيها بنيه حكوميه قائمه ممكن
اذا كان لديها اراده وقدرانها تتحول الى
الى انها تتخذ اجراءات فاعله تحمي بنيه
الدوله بشكل عام ومساعده
كبير هذا يعود الى قيمه ودور المملكه
العربيه تاثيرها في هذا الجانب فاذا قلنا
نحله الملفات نعم السعوديه تحرس توفير
المتطلبات اللي حددها المملكه النظام نعم
ستكون سوري جزء لكن لازم تتحقق لا يمكن
تعود العلاقات بشكل مفتوح هذا ما تريده
الرياض من واشنطن او عفوا هذا ما تريده
الرياض من دمشق لكن بالمقابل ما الذي
تريده دمشق ايضا من الرياض
انا اعتقد انه يعني دمشق ترغب وتتمنى
وترجو وتعمل هذه الخطوه لم تحقق لن تعود
دمشق عمليا الى العالم العربي ولن تنجوا
من ازماتها حتى المحيطه فيها الدوليه
والاقليميه والايرانيه والتعديات
الايرانيه التركيه الا
يعني بهذا الدور السعودي فهي محتاجه الى
كل هذه الخدمات ليست فقط اقتصاديا عادتها
حقيقه
المملكه تريد ان تتبنى سوريا هذا الموقف
الحقيقي وان تقوم بما انت ان تكون يعني
تجري الانتخابات تتعامل مع المواطن بشكل
كامل نحن نجد اليوم الشعب السوري والشعب
مهجر اخر مره عشر مليون مشتتين في هذه
البلد تعاني هذا ازمه وبالتالي نعود الى
نقطه اخرى من اجل ان تتعزز التنميه في
المنطقه لابد يكون هناك استقرار هناك خطوه
جذريه تمت معيران وبشروط محدده وواضحه
وصارمه ودقيقه ايران وهي الخصم الاقليمي
التقليدي اللي كان مشاكل لم تعد العلاقات
معها فقط يعني بالمعنى الاعتباطي لا تمت
وفق وضمانات صارمه وربما هذه الخطوه مع
سوريا اتت بعد هذا الاتفاق دعنا انه سمير
مبدئي على الاقل مع ايران حتى الان
بالبساطه الصينيه هل الدافعه لهذه الخطوه
كان هذا الاتفاق ام كما ذكرت بعض الوكالات
وسائل الاعلام ايضا حتى الغربيه منها بان
هذه الخطوات تمت بوساط روسيه وليست المره
الاولى طبعا الحديث عن البساطه الروسيه في
هذا الملف الجاسر والله لن اعتقد انها
مرتبطه بشكل مباشر بس لكن نقول لعل شهيه
الحكومه في سوريا من رئيس سوريا بعد هذا
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني ان يتغير المزاج
ويتغير بطريقه العمل وندرك انه هو لن
يتحرك في اي مكان السعوديه بتحريك الملف
المياه الراكده وليس البقاء عليها ماذا
سيحدث لو بقينا على هذا الوضع الساكن لن
يتغير شيء ستبقى سوريا تنهار وتدمر وتصبح
يعني حاضنه للمليشيات والجماعات الارهابيه
ولن يتحقق شيء لكن الوساطات ليست مهمه الو
المملكه لا تقبل حتى الوساطه الصينيه او
الرعايه الصينيه لما كانت اتفاق النووي
لضمان تطبيق ايران لشروط السعوديه وليس
لتغيير الموقف فبالتالي اذا كانت هناك
بساطه هي ان يتقبل النظام ما حددته
المملكه من شروط وهي القيام بعمل وطني
يعيد دستوري كل هذا الجهود قيمه لها ما لم
تتحرك لكن اليوم مع المفاوضات في قد
تتحركوا المؤشرات ايجابيه والعوده مهمه
وبالتالي اذا تحقق مثلا العمل ست نهار
الاعمال الارهابيه تحاصر يعني التجاره
المخدرات تهديدات من سوريا للدول العربيه
هل يمكن ان تستعيد سوريا عضويتها في جامعه
الدول العربيه في الاجتماع القادم في مايو
في القمه العربيه في عاصمه السعوديه اذا
جاء الالتزام من بشار الاسد في لحظه واكد
واتخذ الخطوات اللازمه انا اعتقد لا شيء
يمنع نحن نتكلم على اعاده يعني لنقل اعاده
تشكيل المنطقه بالشكل وحمايتها من بشكل
مستقر وبالتالي عادتها الى الوضع الطبيعي
وان تكون فعلا مناخ استقرار وتنميه تتحقق
واستمر هذا المسار سيتحقق الشبكه الدائريه
كامله وبتعود هذا العمل لا يقتصر على
سوريا هناك ليبيا هناك الصومال هناك في
مناطق كثيره في رؤيه شامله يقول هذه السته
اشكرك جزيل الشكر كان معي هنا في
الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي جاسر جاسر شكرا
لك
اكد الكلمه على ضروره تحديد هويه الجسم
المجهول الذي تم اكتشافه بجوار احد خطوط
انابيب
ودع الكرملين الى مواصله التحقيقات في
الانفجارات التي ضربت خطوط الانابيب مشددا
في الوقت ذاته على ضروره ان تتسم بشفافيه
كامله هذا واعتبر
دعوه الدنمارك لروسيا للمساعده في عمليات
البحث عمليه او علامه ايجابيه
ميدانيا اعلنت اوكرانيا عن مقتل سبعه
اشخاص جراء القصف الروسي على مناطق في
شمال وشرق البلاد خدمه الطوارئ في مدينه
دوناتس اكدت ان خمسه مدنين قتلوا في
الهجوم الروسي فيما اعلنت رئاسه
الاوكرانيه عن مقتل شخصين وجرح سبعه اخرين
في منطقه سومي شمال البلاد
قال وزير الخارجيه
محتمله بين بلاده والغرب يجب ان تكون
ملزمه قانونيا وتتضمن اليه واضحه للتحقق
من الامتثال بها واشار لابروف الى ان
علاقات روسيا مع الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي حاليا عند ادنى
مستوياتهم واضاف وزير الخارجيه الروسي انه
اذا عرض الغرب استئناف الاتصالات فستتخذ
موسكو قرارها وفقا للمصالح الروسيه
حذر مجلس الامن الروسي من محاوله اوكرانيا
استعاده القرد مشيرا الى ان ذلك يعد سببا
للرد باي سلاح بما في ذلك النووي قبل ذلك
قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ان القوات الروسيه قد تتقدم الى ان تصل
الى كييف او لفيف في اوكرانيا
فوستي المحليه وحذر من عواقب تصادم اقوى
جيوش العالم قائلا انها ستكون وحشيه
معتبرا كذلك ان الاسلحه المورده لكيف
والمختصون الاجانب الذين وصلوا لاوكرانيا
اهداف مشروعه لروسيا
من موسكو ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد مساء الخير مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ابدا من
تحذير مجلس الامن الروسي من محاوله
استعاده القرم الحديث هنا عن ربما استخدام
السلاح النووي للردع في مواجهه اي محاوله
لاستعاده هذه الجزيره ما الذي اتى من
تصاريح حول هذا الموضوع على رصدته حتى
الان عبد الجواد
مرحبا نايف ورمضان كريم نعم بالفعل صحيح
ما تقول هو نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
والرئيس السابق للبلاد المتري ميديف في
حديث مع الصحفيين يتحدث عن ان موسكو على
علم باستعدادات كيا هجمات على عده محاور
وانهيه الاركان العامه الروسيه في البلاد
تقوم بدراسه طريقه الرد حول هذا الموضوع
طبعا
لقضيه شبه جزيره القرم ووصف محاولات كيف
التقدم نحو السيطره او محاوله استعادتها
انها ستكون هدف يعني متاح لكافه الاسلحه
الروسيه مهما كان نوعها وان عقيده الردع
الروسيه بما يخص الدرع النوويه ستكون
حاضره وقد تستخدم موسكو او تذهب لاستخدام
هذا الموضوع في حال طبعا شنه كيف هجمات
واسعه لاستعاده شبه جزيره ايضا
عن ان موسكو اليوم تواجه جيش الناتو بشكل
كامل يعني وصف الرقم وحدده بانه ثلاثه
ملايين الف جندي تقوم بمواجهتهم موسكو
وحديثه يدور حول طبعا مواجهه في الدعم
الغربي لنظام كيف والاراضي الاوكرانيه
والنظام هناك تفضل نايف كنت تسال كذلك هو
اشاره نقطه مهمه ربما هي يعني تدور حول
ريحه الحديث الذي ذكرته قبل قليل فيما يخص
وصول موسكو الى في حديث يعني بين القوات
الروسيه قد تتقدم الى كييف الى لفيف غرب
البلاد طبعا في اوكرانيا ما هي الظروف
والمحددات لهذا التقدم للقوات الروسيه ان
كان قد اتى على ذكرها
ما في يعني ما يشهده الصراع الاوكراني
خلال الاسبوع الاخير حول طبعا الازمه من
مرحله عض الاصابع بين موسكو والغرب الى
مرحله كسر العظام خاصه بعد ادراج الرئيس
الروسي ضمن قائمه يعني الجنائيه الدوليه
واصدار مذكره اعتقال في حقه حول هذا
الصراع لتصعيد كبير ودفعه بشكل متسارع نحو
الامامي لذلك طبعا رد موسكو اليوم يعني
يعتبر قاسيا في قضيه التصريحات نوعا ما
كما تقرا كما يقرا التحليل السياسي في
البلاد اليوم يعني مرحله الفيف ومرحله
تكيف كانت موسكو قد تحدثت عنها سابقا الا
انها اليوم حاضره في معظم التصريحات وهذا
طبعا
من جديد للحديث بان يعني التقدم نحو
الارقى الاوكرانيه يعني كسر نظام كيف بشكل
كامل يعني الوصول لنقطه مغلقه بما يخص
قضيه الحوار مع الغرب او طبعا الحكومه
الاوكرانيه هي مغلقه بشكل كبير ولذلك طبعا
معروف بان صاحب التصريحات الناريه يمكنه
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع طبعا قد لا يكون
هذا الشيء بشكل جدي وبشكل قاطع يعني شن
عمليات عسكريه او ضربات صاروخيه على كيف
ولف لكنه طبعا دخل في تصريحات ولابد من
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار حسب القراءه السياسيه
في البلاد لذلك طبعا نايف قضيه ما خرج به
من حديث مطوله اليوم مع الصحفيين بدات
بالهجمات على الاراضي الروسيه وان موسكو
ستقوم بالرد حتى ولو بسلاح نووي وانتهت
بقضيه طبعا ردع الناتو والوصول للحديث عن
مواجهه موسكو لكافه جيوش الناتو وعددها
يصل الى ثلاثه ملايين الف جندي جاهزون كما
يرى اشكرك جزيل الشكر من موسكو مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الراشد
شكرا الرابعه مستمره تتابعون فيها بعد
قليل ايضا وزير السياحه السعودي يكشف عن
تسجيل مليوني ونصف المليون زائر من الخارج
خلال فبراير الماضي
حياكم الله من جديد في السعوديه اطلقت
وزاره الموارد البشريه المنصه الوطنيه
للمسؤوليه الاجتماعيه بالتزامن مع مرور
اليوم العالمي للمسؤوليه الاجتماعيه والذي
يصادف الثالث والعشرين من مارس تدشين
المنصات جاء خطوه ضمن خطوات التحول الرقمي
لتمكين المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه في القطاع
الخاص وابرازي اثرها التنموي بالاضافه الى
قياس مستهدفاتها بالتكامل مع جميع
القطاعات
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو مدير عمل
المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه بوزاره الموارد
البشريه الدكتور مبارك البقمي دكتور مبارك
حياك الله معي في نشاط الرابع كل عام
وانتم بخير رمضان كريم اولا علينا نبارك
لكم اطلاق هذه المنصه وخلينا نسال اول
نعرف المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه ما هي
المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الله يحييكم
فيما يخص المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه المسؤوليه
الاجتماعيه مفهوم قديم تطور عبر الزمن
اخذ في جانبه المسؤوليه تجاه المجتمع ولكن
حديثا اخذ مفهوم متعلق بالقطاع الخاص
ظهر له مواصفات قياسيه عالميه بمسمى ايزو
26 الف حددت المفهوم ومن خلاله تم تحديد
مفهوم النسويه الاجتماعيه في المملكه
بينها اثر او التزام منشات القطاع الخاص
تجاه
خلق اثر مستدام في المجتمع والاقتصاد
وبالتالي هذه المنصه هي المنصه التي يعني
تحفز هذا العمل الذي ذكرته
وتجعل ايضا كمان هذه الشركات والقطاع
الخاص ايضا يساهم بعمل الاجتماع من خلالها
المنصه هي مجتمع تقني عملت الوزاره مع
شركائها من خلال هذا المجتمع انت ان تجعل
المسؤوليه اجتماعيه بين يدي القطاع الخاص
من خلالها يمكن يلتقي مع القطاع العام ومع
القطاع غير الربحي اللي خلق شركات مثمره
ومفيده للمجتمع والاقتصاد والبيئه ايضا
ممكن من خلالها القطاع الخاص بنفسه يقدم
مبادراته ويفصح عنها للمجتمع من خلال هذه
المنصه نستطيع ان نعرف
مدى مساهمات القطاع الخاص في التنميه
المستدامه من خلالها ايضا نجود ممارسات
الخاص وتتوجه
باتجاه تحقيق او سد الاحتياج التنموي
المربوط بالاحتياجات التنمويه بالمملكه
ايضا نستطيع رصد مستوى التقدم
في ممارسه الشركات المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه
وايضا يعتبر منصه لرفع الوعي بالمسؤوليه
الاجتماعيه وتطوير ايضا
لها في وقت سابقي المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه
كانت تتخطى تقريبا 30% واليوم ارتفعت هذه
النسب ايضا ممارسات الشركات الكبيره
في اول قياس لمده اطلاق الاستراتيجيه في
2019 كانت بنسبه 30% اليوم الحمد نفخر بنا
وصلنا الى مستوى 60% من الشركات الكبيره
تمارس النسويه الاجتماعيه ولديها برامج
ممتازه خلني اسال هنا عن دور هذه القطاعات
يعني دور القطاعات خصوص القطاعات القطاع
الخاص في هذه المنصه تحديدا منصه المنصه
الوطنيه المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه ايش دورهم
انا لو ابدخل اليوم هذه المنصه
واتجول يعني فيها واحاول اشوف وش تقدم هذه
القطاعات في هذه المنصه حتى اكون راضي ويش
المفروض يكون فيها المنصه تجمع ثلاث
قطاعات القطاع العام والقطاع غير الربحي
والقطاع الخاص المسؤول عن المسؤوليه
الاجتماعيه هو القطاع الخاص القطاع الخاص
سيسجل في المنصه المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه
صحيح مبادراته ولكن سيجد ايضا من القطاع
العام والقطاع الغربي تواجد يبرز
مبادراتهم المشاريع التي تحتاج الى شراكه
مع كليهما ايضا سيجد الاحتياج التنموي
موجود بين يديه محدد حتى بالخارطه
التنمويه في جميع المناطق نعرف انه
الاجتماعيه في الشركات مرتبطه
باستراتيجياتها فهي في الشركه ينطلق من
تنطلق من استراتيجيه الشركه فمن خلالها
ومن خلال استراتيجيه ممكن تتوجه لي سد
الاحتياج التنموي او اختيار المبادرات
والمشاريع التي تتفق مع
استراتيجياتها وممارستها المسؤوليه ليش
تضمنت المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه للجوانب
الاقتصادي
المثلث الاستدامه الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
والبيئي باعاده الشركات عندما تبدا تبحث
عن الربحيه هي المسؤوليه بمعنى تربح هي
مسؤوليه عن مسؤوله او التي يجب ان يكون
لديها مسؤوليه اجتماعيه اذا تحركت عجله
الاقتصاد تؤثر يعني
تؤثر على المجتمع وعلى البيئه دور
المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه هو موازنه لتتم
المحافظه على الاستدامه او ان يكون العمل
او التنميه مستدامه باذن الله بالتوفيق
لكم ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك على حضورك
معي هنا في استديو الرابعه مدير عام
المسؤوليه الاجتماعي بوزاره الموارد
البشريه الدكتور مبارك
قبل اقل من 24 ساعه على اطلاقها نجحت حمله
اكتتاب جوده الاسكان الخيري في السعوديه
في جمع اكثر من 421 مليون ريال وذلك ضمن
هدفها بجمع مليون ريال حتى نهايه الشهر
رمضان الجاريه التفاصيل مع زميل عبد
المحسن الحربي
[تصفيق]
بطريقه مبتكره في العمل الخيري دق الجرسون
ياذن ببدء اكبر حمله اكتتاب في قطاع
الاسكان الخيري في العالم
بمشاركه واسعه من عدد من الوزراء ورجال
الاعمال بهدف جمع مليار ريال سعودي خلال
شهر منصه جود احد المنصات اللي بتساعد في
تسهيل وصول زكاتك او صدقاتك للمحتاجين
وانت تختار الاسره التي ترى انها افضل
للدعم انت الذي تحدد وانت تروح اموالك
فيها المنصه تضمن ان هذه المبالغ تذهب
مباشره للمستفيد وتكون انت جزء من سعاده
هذه الاسر ان شاء الله في شهر الخير
والعطاء نشكر حكومه خادم الحرمين الشريفين
على اتاحه لنا مثل هذه البرامج وهذه
الاستثمارات الناجحه لخدمه الوطن والمواطن
في هذا لتامين السكن المناسب لابناء
ابنائنا المحتاجين من المواطنين بمجرد
الاعلان عن الاكتتاب توالت اعلانات
المساهمه والتي تشنت بمبلغ مئه وخمسين
مليون ريال من الملك سلمان وولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان لصالح الحمله التي
تستهدف تامين ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه مسكن
للاسر الاكثر احتياجا اليوم اكتتاب جودي
عدل الاول من نوعه على مستوى العالم
وبالذات في مجال الاسكان اليوم اعتقد
التفاعل الكبير اللي صار من قبل رجال
الاعمال من قبل هي العمل الاوقاف هو تفاعل
فريد في اول يوم يغطى تقريبا 25% من
الاكتتاب هذا بحد ذاته حافز كبير جدا على
ان شاء الله انه سيتجاوز ايضا المليار
ريال باذن الله
ستستمر حمله اكتتاب جود الاسكان الخيري
طوال شهر رمضان باست قبال مساهمات
الاكتتاب التي تستهدف ان تصل لمليار ريال
من خلال طرح مئه مليون سفن عبد المحسن
الحربي العربيه الرياض
اذا اطلقت منصه وجود الاسكان في السعوديه
حمله اكتتاب جود الاسكان الخيري كاول
اكتتاب خيري في العالم عن طريق المحاكاه
حيث تستهدف المنصه من الحمله كبر المانحين
من المؤسسات والافراد والقطاعين العام
والخاص وكذلك الفرد العادي راس مال
اكتتابي حمله جود الاسكان الخيري مشاهدينا
يبلغ مليار ريال سعودي وذلك حسب نشره
الاصدار مقسم على مئه مليون سهم بقيمه
اسميه لسهم تبلغ 10 ريالات هذا الطرح
الخيري مشاهدينا يهدف الى توفير المسكن
لثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه اسره شديده الحاجه
اسهم وجود مشاهدينا تعطي حاملها منحه سهم
واحد في هيئه الاوقاف السعوديه مقابل كل
عشرتك كل عشره اكتتب بها المنصه مشاهدينا
وفي نشره اصدارها كشفت بان كبار المانحين
وهم المتبرعون باكثر من خمسه ملايين ريال
سيحق لهم الحصول على تقرير مفصل
للاسر التي استفادت من التبرع هذه الحمله
ليست الاولى لمنصه جود الاسكان حيث سبق
وان نجحت في العوامل الثلاثه الماضيه من
خلال حملات مختلفه الى جمع ما يزيد عن
475 مليون ريال
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عن
استفاده اكثر من مليون شخص من مليون شخص
بين معتمر ومصلي وزائر من منظومه الخدمات
المتكامله في المسجد الحرام بالتزامن مع
مرور اول يوم من شهر رمضان هذا وكان عشرات
الالاف من المصلين قد ادوا اليوم صلاه
الجمعه الاولى في شهر رمضان
الجاري وسط خطه متكامله من الخدمات
الامنيه والصحيه
اعلنت الاداره العمل للمرور في السعوديه
عن جاهزيتها لموسم العمره في العام الحالي
وذلك من خلال تنظيم وتسهيل حركه السير
وضمان سلامه المشاه بالاضافه الى اداره
حركه التنقل في مكه والمدينه المنوره كما
عملت الاداره على متابعه الحركه المروريه
للمصلين وزوار الحرم المكي
ومن الحرم المكي الشريف ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي سلطان مساء الخير كل
عام وانت بخير رمضان كريم وقبل قليل كنا
نستعرض جاهزيه المرور لموسم العمره في هذا
الشهر وانت طبعا بالقرب من احد المركبات
وموجود ايضا بالقرب ايضا حتى من الطرق
المؤديه للحرم المكي كيف رصدت الاجواء
والحاله العامه حتى الان المروريه
نعم اهلا بك نايف اهلا بكافه مشاهدي نشره
الرابعه وكل عام وانتم بخير في اول جمعه
من شهر رمضان نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره شهداء
الحرم المكي منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى مما
استدعى مضاعفه العمل القطاعات الامنيه
وتحديدا نتحدث على قطاع المرور الذي يعمل
على تنظيم حركه السير والمشاه هنا في
الطرق المؤديه الى الحرم المكي وكذلك فيما
يتعلق بالتاكد من سلامه عمليات النقل من
خلال محطات النقل العام وحتى سيارات
الاجره وكذلك الحافلات الخاصه بحافلات مكه
نتحدث كذلك عن استعدادات كبيره عملت عليها
القطاعات الامنيه لتنظيم
تنظيم دخول المعتمرين وخروج المصلين كذلك
طوال شهر رمضان في الحرم المكي وكذلك
مناطق المجاوره تفاصيل حول كيفيه استيعاب
الاعداد المليونين المليونيه المتوقعه
التي سوف تصل الحرم المكي طوال شهر رمضان
ينضم اليه العقيد منصور بن عبيد الشكاره
المتحدث الرسمي باسم اداره المرور بدايه
اهلا وسهلا بك على شاشه العربيه من
المتوقع وصول اعداد مليونيه اعداد كبيره
من المركبات والحافلات نشهدها بشكل مستمر
بالقرب من الحرم المكي لانزال المعتمرين
او حتى المصلين كيف تتعاملون مع هذه
التدفقات اسعد الله مساءك اخوي سلطان
ومساك كل من يشاهدنا عبر قناه العربيه
وتقبل الله من الجميع طاعاتهم قيادات قوه
امن العمره لشؤون المرور تعمل وفق خطط
ميدانيه وتشغيليه بدانا فيها منذ بدايه
الساعات الباكره لدخول شهر رمضان المبارك
وذلك باستقبال المعتمرين من المواقف
الخارجيه التي على مداخل العاصمه المقدسه
والاشراف على انتقال المعتمرين الى
المحطات الداخليه القريبه من المنطقه
المركزيه ايضا التحكم في تدفق حركه النقل
العام ما بين
المواقف انزال المعتمرين وكذلك الوصول الى
المنطقه المركزيه لضمان انسيابيه الحركه
وايضا لضمان سلامه المعتمرين كم لدينا
محور او طريق او نفق او مواقع مخصصه
للمشاه للوصول للحرم المكي لدينا العديد
من المحاور
والمشاه طبعا هم في الدرجه الاولى
للاستخدام الطرق والمحاور يتم ايضا التحكم
بدخول المركبات من قبل النقاط الفرز
والتحكم الداخليه ولدينا ايضا نقاط فرز
وتحكم خارجيه لمتابعه الحركه في المنطقه
المحيطه بالحرم والسماح بتدفق المركبات في
حاله السمع وفي حاله ارتفاع منسوب المشاه
يتم ايضا تقليص عدد المركبات لضمان امن
وسلامه المشاه ماذا عن محطات الخاصه بنقل
المعتمرين القادمين من خارج مدينه مكه يتم
استقبالهم مثل ما اسلفنا في المواقف
الخارجيه وعددها 5 على مداخل العاصمه
المقدسه يتم ايقاف المركبات الخاصه
بالمعتمرين انتقالهم بوسائل النقل العام
وصولا الى المحطات الداخليه وانتقالا الى
المنطقه الحرم والمنطقه المركزيه يوم امس
شاهدنا اعداد كبيره تتحرك باتجاه الحرم
المكي اثناء مرور المركبات كيف تتعاملون
مع هذه السيابيه رجال الامن ورجال المرور
هم رجال اكفاء ومدربون ولديهم من الخبرات
السابقه التي تمكنهم من اداره وتنظيم
الحركه والتحكم في تدفق الكثافات بما يضمن
سلامه المعتمر والزائر باذن الله شكرا لك
كان معنا العقيد منصور بن عبيد اشكر
المتحدث الرسمي باسم المديريه العامه
للمرور نتحدث اليوم عن عدد كبير من
القطاعات الامنيه التي تعمل بشكل مباشر في
الحرم المكي والساحات الخارجيه وكذلك
الطرق والشوارع المجاور للحرم المكي
للتاكد من سلامه وصول المركبات بشكل كبير
وانزال المعتمرين المصلين الى الحرم
المكينا امنا يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا
لكم من الحرم المكي الشريف مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي انت وظيفك الكريم
مجمع الملك عبد العزيز مشاهدينا بمكه هو
الجهه المختصه التي تعنى بحياه ثوب الكعبه
والاهتمام به منذ 80 عاما
بيدي امهر الحرفيين السعوديين الذين تلقوا
التدريب والتاهيل وذلك عبر الات النسيج
والتطريز الحديث التي يتم تحديثها كل عام
ويضم المجمع 200 حيره وبتكلفه تصل الى
عشرين مليون ريال للثوب سنويا التفاصيل
ايضا مع الزميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
وظائف متوارثه مصطلح رمزي للكثير من
الوظائف المرتبطه بالحج والعمره في مكه
منذ عقود طويله ابراهيم نوفل حرفي تمسك
بمهنه والده وهي
حياكه كسوه الكعبه شكل من خلالها علاقه
وطيده مع الحرير والخيوط المذاهبه طوال
اربعين عام هذا المهنه بالنسبه لي انا شرف
ربي اعلم قديش بحب هذه المهنه لكن حبي في
الشغله هذه انا ما صدقت
ملكيه من الله سبحانه وتعالى
من مجرد مزارع المهنه هادئه على طول في
المكان اليدويه القديمه صار الانحراف
القاعده والاصبع زي ما انتم شايفين وكذا
يعني بيختلف الاصبع الثاني وهذا شرف ربي
اكرمنا فيه احنا لمسات الحرير بالنسبه لنا
البصمه راحت من يوم ما بدات تعييني في
العمل وانا شغال فيها يعني تقريبا سته
بضعوا سنوات تفصل بين هذا الحرفي الذي قضى
جل عمره في حياكه كسوه الكعبه وبين الفصل
الاخير من عمله لاقترابه من سن التقاعد ما
جعله ياخذ بيد ابنه عمر
لتعليمه هذه المهنه واكمال مسيره العائله
حتى الحب للوظيفه دي من الوالد وقبلها كان
جدي شغلتنا
فالحب كان عن طريقهم
وكملت انا الحمد لله الحين اربع سنوات
عظيمه وكانت السنه اللي فاتت كانت اول مره
اطلع فوق الكعبه
مشاركه في تلبيس الثوب
وكان شيء شعور لا يوفر مجمع الملك عبد
العزيز لكسوه الكعبه
مئات الوظائف لشباب وشابات السعوديه
بهدف انجاز المهمه السنويه لكسوه الكعبه
التي تتجاوز تكلفتها عشرين مليون ريال في
كل عام
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير السياحه السعودي احمد الخطيب على
ان قطاع سياحه في السعوديه سجل ارقاما
تاريخيه من حيث نسب الاشغال وعدد الزوار
من خارج البلاد خلال العام الجاري حيث بلغ
عدد الزوار البلاد خلال شهر يناير حوالي
اثنين مليون و400 الف زائر قادم من خارج
المملكه فيما زاد العدد خلال فبراير
الماضي الذي شهد دخول مليونين ونصف
المليون اي ما يقارب ثلاثه اي ما يقارب
ثلاثه وثمانين الف زائر يوميا وشدد الخطيب
على ان اهميه توطين القطاع مهمه مشيرا الى
ان الوزاره انفقت 400 مليون ريال لتدريب
وتاهيل 100,000 شاب وشابه في قطاع السياحه
عادات يوميه متعدده تتغير بدخول شهر رمضان
ومع هذا التغير تطرب ساعات النوم الامر
الذي يتبعه او يتبعه تاثيرات صحيه مختلفه
على الصعيد الجسدي والنفسي حيث اوضح
المركز السعودي لتعزيز الصحه النفسيه ان
النوم المتقطعه من الاضطرابات الشائعه
خلال شهر رمضان ما يؤثر سلبا على مستوى
التركيز والاداء خلال النهار كما يضاعف
ايضا من خطر الاصابه بالامراض
من الرياض ينضم الينا مدير المركز الجامعي
لطب وابحاث النوم بجامعه الملك سعود
الدكتور احمد بهمام دكتور احمد حياك الله
كل عام وانتم بخير رمضان كريم اولا بدايه
هل يعني بالضروره دخول شهر رمضان المبارك
حتميه اضطراب ساعات النوم لدى الصائمين
لدى كل الافراد
مساكم الله بالخير
شهر رمضان في بعض الدول ومنها المملكه
يصاحب تغيرات في نمط الحياه
مما يشجع على السهر بالليل والنوم بالنهار
مثلا تاخير ساعات الدوام للانشطه الليليه
المختلفه ايضا استمرار البعض في الاكل
طوال الليل كل هذه الامور تؤثر على الساعه
البيولوجيه للجسم وقد تؤدي الى تاخير في
النوم وهذا طبعا التاخير الحاد انه وحتى
لو استمر خلال الشهر كامل له تاثيرات صحيه
سيئه على عمليات الايض او التمثيل الغذائي
وما يتبعها من دار الخطر اللي صار بالسكري
والسمنه
ومتلازمه الايض وايضا على القلب على
الاوعيه الدمويه على ضغط الدم على خطر لا
قدر الله ايضا
هناك اختلال حاد في خلايا الجسم المختلفه
التي تتبع ايقاع يومي او ساعه بيولوجيه
جميع الخلايا فيها جينات تتبع ايقاع يومي
هذا الاقتراب الحاد يؤدي الى مثل هذه
التغيرات في احد الدراسات الامريكيه ذكرت
بانه الفرد
في العمل يتحسن عندما يحصل على قسط كافي
من النوم الجيد وقالت ايضا
هذه الابحاث اثرت ان النوم يؤثر ايضا حتى
في مستويات الجوع والشبع هذه كيف نقدر
نربطها بفترات الصيام التي تصل تقريبا ل
13 ساعه في اليوم يا دكتور بمعنى هل الشخص
الذي يحصل على نوم وقسط كافي من النوم
ممكن ان تتعزز لديه
يعني مساله الشبع وان يعني لا يضطر ربما
للجوع خلال ساعات اليوم
هناك توصيات وطنيه سعوديه من هيئه الصحه
العامه والوقايه بخصوص مده النوم الصحيه
جميع الفئات العمريه
كان مده النوم الصحيه في شهر رمضان هذه
التوصيات او صينا باربعه الى ست ساعات نوم
ليلي خلال ليالي رمضان وتعويض ذلك بعد ذلك
في النهار في ساعه ونصف الى ساعتين حتى
يحصل الشخص على ما يحتاجه من حوالي ثمان
ساعات شخص البالغ
النوم الليلي يقلل من الجوع بالنهار وهذا
امر ايضا معروف ومثبت بعد نوم ساعات كافيه
ثمان ساعات لا يستيقظ الشخص وهو يشعر
بالجوع البقاء مستيقظ الشخص طوال الليل
يزداد معه الجوع وهذا ايضا مثبت علميا
يزداد الجوع يزداد افراز هرمون الجوع
ومقاومه الجسم هرمون الشبع الليبتين ايضا
هناك ابحاث كثيره منها نحن عملناها التعرض
للضوء خلال الليل الضوء الساطع طوال الليل
ايضا يفتح الشهيه ويزيد في تناول النشويات
والكربوهيدرات والسكريات مما يسبب زياده
دكتور احنا هنا نفهم انه يعني من ينام
بشكل كافي ياخذ قسط كافي من النوم خلال
ساعات الليل مبكرا اليوم الاخر في يوم
الصيام لا يشعر بالجوع مثل الشخص الذي ظل
يعني سهران طول الليل نعم هذا قد يكون
يعني نعم يفسر بهذا الشكل ايضا هناك
التوصيات بس نقطه اخيره انه يكون الوجبات
يعني وجبه افطار او حول وقت الافطار وجبه
سحول وقد يكون بينهم سناك خفيف ونوم بعد
ست ساعات بين الوجبتين هذا امر اساسي
للصحه العامه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الرياض
مدير المركز الجامعي لطب ابحاث جامعه
الملك سعود الدكتور احمد شكرا يا دكتور
ختام رابعه بابرز عناوينها
واشنطن تقول بان العمليات في سوريا تهدف
لحمايه قوتها وتحذر ايران من التورط في
الهجمات عليها
مصدر في الخارجيه السعوديه يكشف عن
محادثات مع دمشق الاستئناف الخدمات
القنصليه بين البلدين
الموارد البشريه السعوديه تطلق منصه
الكترونيه لتمكين المسؤوليه الاجتماعيه
للقطاع الخاص
خلال اقل من 24 ساعه اكتتاب جود الخير في
السعوديه يجمع قرابه نصف مليار
عائله سعوديه تتوارث مهنه حياكه ثوب
الكعبه منذ اكثر من سته عقود بمجمع الملك
عبد العزيز بمكه
شكرا لكم لكرمي المتابعه نهايه الرابعه
عود والقاكم يوم غد في رعايه الله